last time we were looking at graphs in
the complex player we looked at very
very simple brows okay but remember we
looked at graphs like say this right we
approach it algebraically we approach it
geometrically and we determined well how
would you describe verbally how would
you describe the walkers traced out by
this it's a circle what else can you
tell me about it where is it where is it
where is it placed it's at the center at
the origin edge radius is 2 because in
fact by definition that's what it means
right the modulus is the distance from
the origin so it's the distance from the
origin to Zed is 2 so therefore it has
they used to shoot ok
we looked at some the inner qualities we
look at stuff like this I think this was
a great investor we looked at this you
have to just tackle them algebraically
so here you can see your imaginary
component to get a cancel out which
leaves you with just couple the real
component you do your algebra you get a
region that accords with that ok and on
an RV trip
now we're gonna push a little further on
this and up we're gonna need our
compasses to help us so we'll get there
here's the first alright now before we
tackle this guy and do any algebra with
it ok or or any geometry I just want you
to remember back to when we were doing
vectors and we said okay Michael exam 1
I've got to say here where were roughly
speaking where would the position vector
of z1 take away said where would you
expect to go how would you roughly
describe so he said to write so if I'm
thinking about Ted one takeaway is that
you should be thinking up the negation
of there too so everything's at the
first question of it so the Gatien will
come over here to the third quadrant out
here right so then where what's gonna
happen combine them ok yeah I'm gonna
put that one here before I put that one
in the position vector position vector
is coming off of the origin right so
really
this guy right that'll be someone's a
joke I'm doing it very roughly okay now
we can see because the parallelogram law
that if that is that what might I said
to the position vector I can consider a
free vector parallel to that up here
okay that's very important which
direction it's going right I hope you
can see why it has to be going that way
has to be going that way if you consider
the position vector always come back to
the position vector because you can
compute that just by a straight forward
like if you know what these numbers up
right
like okay let's just do some guesswork
okay under there maybe that's something
like five plus I won't might that be one
plus 4i or something like that okay
so what you do zedd one takeaway said to
do the real parts first you're gonna get
four I take away 4 I minus 3i so it's
got to be down there and once you've got
the position vector you know which
direction it's going to you and then you
can move around and consider the free
vectors okay so critically important
that you see it's in that direction okay
as it he said therefore since it's up
there
this really is another way of saying
what's the distance between said what is
it to write what is that distance there
okay now what is this movement when I
see you stay over here this is again a
distance between two complex numbers the
first complex number is a variable just
like if these cases it's gonna move
around just like the normal point in a
lot of stars but then this guy is well
where's he let's get a drawing shall we
let's consider this geometrically we'll
do the algebra a minute when I said
simple takeaway said to write I made
this this point over here which is
positive positive and this point over
here which is also positive positive ok
so what I say this Z take away to I the
point of considering is not negative 2i
it's 2 pi right Zed's one point two eyes
the other point and I'll find the
distance between them right that's
subtraction doesn't meet the point is
minus 2i
it means I'm comparing them I'm taking
the difference ok so therefore what this
means is if I can write this for you
this up left hand side be the distance
from 0 to the complex point to I right
now this makes sense back in terms of a
mood swing about changing the frame of
reference right if I just say what's in
that's just the distance from the origin
which is really really should be written
like this right because you're comparing
the distance from said to 0 the origin
ok but now I'm taking my point of
reference to I is there my scent on ok
so that's worth comparing for all right
if the left hand side figure this
assumes it to I what is that my head
side me it's not in the right form for
us at the Bourbon how could I change it
it should be absolute values then take
away something right you see that take
away something that's what tells you to
compare distances what am i subtracting
yeah I've got to have a double negative
there to get my positive and then I've
got plus I right so why this 1 plus I
that's another point and I comparing my
distance to that as well so if I have a
1 2 this 2 I there because I'm on the
imaginary axis he's the real axis minus
1 plus i these are going this way one
unit and then I go up what do you do so
that there is minus 1 plus I'm ok
I had to be tricky because this is the
this point the boy is - I but where is
on the axis is why it was - does that
make sense because I'm talking to
measure no unity okay so it's a bit see
you're weird and I you could label this
- or you can label it - I different okay
now hold on a second what does this mean
I want the locus of points then are the
same distance from 2i as they are from
minus 1 plus I ok well we did this one
we're out of the basketball courts right
now we're gonna go up last one course
again without compasses when I asked
YouTube it's a go stand somewhere I've
got two people here go stand somewhere
so you're the same distance from both
people okay immediately someone was
cheap and they rated the easy spot
namely ver the midpoint right so they go
right there okay but that was not the
only point okay
in fact because of the numbers that we
wish we chose it here there's another
really easy point you could see this
point right here that's I isn't it can
you see why that's obviously the same
distance there zone is 1 and 1 ok now I
can keep going right there's another
cheap point there and I can Street these
together right we know what shape this
is what what light of my Tracy girl if I
put this lady
I'll get the equation in a second but
what kind of light is it what's verbally
how do I describe okay it's a straight
light obviously right but it's not just
any straight line is perpendicular and
because it goes through the midpoint
it's the bisector okay so this like here
but what do serve these points right is
the perpendicular bisector of V 2 I 2
minus 1 plus 5 ok now because you can
give it really easy numbers in this case
right I think we can probably work out
what the equation of this line is right
what does the gradient look like to you
looks like minus 1 how you do it's minus
1
good so if that agree it's easy to see
it's what I'll let the perpendicular to
its negative one so I'm going to get
something in the form Y it could - X
what's by Y descent it's plus one okay
so that's the equation that I guess it
can I verify it algebraically hmm